the alpine lake in jagged mountains look
picturesque but they are in fact the
first line of defense for a data bolt
inside an old Swiss Army Command Center
surveillance and infrared cameras doors
must be closed before the next can open
fingerprints can match individual badges
module entrance wanted at a time I'm
walking inside the mountain it's about a
70 meter long tunnel I've gone through
seven security barriers biometric three
nuclear blast walls and I still have a
couple more barriers to go including a
hermetically sealed door you we have
free covers stefan brooch a karate black
belt and former french air force officer
purchased the bunker one of 16,000 from
the Swiss Army in 2007
reservoirs of mountain water here enough
to drink help cool the server's lowering
the electric bill clients can rent racks
or rows of storage lockers or even an
entire room an air shaft for ventilation
there's a sickbay a post office and a
map room if cyber commandos come in
storm or try to storm this bunker you
can shoot at them through these
apertures a self-contained city designed
for an attack that never came the
security concept is like an onion you
have several layers and before you get
into the dye room you have eight layers
of security access but the biggest
security risk is internal what you have
to be careful about is more to be
careful about your stuff about your
customers when they're getting when they
have when they give you an idea proper
idea that they have bad intentions
that's what you really have to be
careful about they could be posing as
journalists they could that's why we're
going to check you before getting pants
Legos Bloomberg Switzerland